tout ce que je recherche avec un
magazine us et confidentialité m'ayez
pas compris que dumont a rejoint de dado
enchanteur et puis je crois qu'il n'y a
rien qui paraît sur canada que mon nom
pas d'espagne pendant qu'une transaction
lui c'est un faux clients en fait c'est
un collaborateur qu'on a recruté pour un
reportage qu'on prépare sur le
blanchiment d'argent dans l'immobilier à
montréal est ce qu'on a voulu savoir c
est ce que les courtiers immobiliers
accepterait vraiment de procéder à une
transaction immobilière en sachant
clairement que l'argent provient du
trafic de stupéfiants ça me dérange pas
du tout d'abord un produit mon meilleur
ami son mari c'est la même chose bon je
comprends que ça vienne de notre cour
on a monté un scénario de toute pièce et
on a demandé à notre collaborateur
d'aller dans des propriétés qu'on a
choisi au hasard tout des propriétés de
luxe
et là notre collaborateur aller voir les
courtiers et leur dire clairement
d'abord que son argent provenait de la
drogue beaucoup d'argent dans de menus
stupéfiants qui voulait pas donc une
façon question nom soit associé à cette
transaction la fête aujourd'hui les
transactions seront pas le temps là on
évite même des courriers et qu'en aucun
moment de la transaction y allait
fournir des pièces d'identité je veux
demander des pièces du processus c'est
un affront si vous n'êtes pas l'acheter
non à mulhouse a pas le choix
ni maintenant ni jamais mais mes voeux
les plus tard on n'est jamais sûr non
que ce serait en fait sa copine qui
allaient signer pour la transaction donc
en quelque sorte notre compagnie ou
mélissa j0 problème avec ça il ya
plusieurs rapports qui disent qu'il ya
un gros problème de blanchiment d'argent
dan immobiliers au canada et ces mêmes
rapports disent que les courtiers qui
ont l'obligation légale de rapporter ces
transactions la dès qu'ils ont un
soupçon qu'elle peut être douteuse mais
qui ne font pas
vois pas où il ya un problème c'est un
achat comptant ça passe par les banques
ce qui nous a vraiment surpris en fait
c'est que tous les courtiers immobiliers
ont accepté les conditions de notre
client toxé compter sur moi j'ai bien vu
que je suis un point tel en fait qu'on
s'est dit ben il faudrait peut-être
organiser une deuxième série de visites
peut-être qu'ils ont eu peur lors de la
rencontre donc on leur a donné du temps
pour réfléchir et on organisait une
deuxième série pour voir tout ce qui
nous a encore plus surpris c'est qu' à
aucun des courtiers qui a refusé notre
demande de deuxième visite dans les
heures qui ont suivi on a quand même
reçu 3 et baldas dasher 3
ok il faut que l'opération était
terminée
j'ai appelé les cinq courtiers de
m'appelle julie du feng shui violoniste
et radio canada pour l'émission enquête
et c'est là que leur annoncer qu en fait
un personnage fictif ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que tous les courtiers immobiliers
se sont défendus d'avoir manqué à leurs
obligations légales
plusieurs d'entre eux ont aussi dit que
dans leur esprit était pas du tout
question de faire du blanchiment
d'argent
il y en a plusieurs aussi qu'ils nous
ont dit qu'ils avaient l'intention de
faire une déclaration d'opérations
douteuses mais une fois la transaction
complétée
d'autres aussi qui nous ont dit que dans
leur esprit c'était la copine qu'il
fallait identifier parce que c'est elle
qui allait signer les documents sur tout
mais s'occupe aux crochets de recul on
peut pas penser que c'est une pure
coïncidence calé cinq courtiers
immobiliers qu'on a rencontrés sont les
seuls qui aurait accepté de faire la
transaction qu'on leur proposait en fait
c'est probablement révélateur d'un
problème qui est beaucoup plus grave qui
est probablement systémique à montréal
et au canada
[Musique]